think you've said right for emotion not
for gimmicks
yeah i think that um i think sometimes
writers
particularly when writers are starting
from
concepts and not really delving into
the reason why people show up which is
the character you know characters are
motivated by their emotions right so
when you are
writing and you're writing from just
plot
it's less engaging than if you're
writing from character well what is this
character going to do why would they
want to do this what's the reason
you know who are the stakes that they're
doing it for
when you've got those things and you're
working from
the inside out it's a lot more emotional
it's a lot i i will connect to your
material a lot more we will all feel
something
when you know when you're writing from
the inside out as opposed to the outside
in and you can start with the outside
obviously you need something you know
plot to hang it on but if you're not
doing the work underneath it
if you're just giving you know
cool
fight scenes
and you're not really
delving into well why is there a fight
scene then
you're going to lose your audience for
sure
so let's say if i'm doing a
coming-of-age drama of some
woman that's hanging out at venice beach
all the time and she's kind of
floundering and she's doesn't know if
she's going to go to college doesn't
know if she can even afford to go but
it's a cool gimmick and we can have cool
skateboarders and all these interesting
characters around her but i'm not
getting to really her story i'm just
it's too flat
well i think you have to get underneath
the character and figure out well what
is she really motivated what does she
want to do what's her goal because you
don't want a passive character who's
just sitting on the beach you want
someone who wants to do something so
what is that some thing and then why
does she want to do that thing
so if you have to you know it writing is
is is really unearthing so much of
um
you know you have to get underneath
everything in order to have something
that really resonates
and uh and that's the hard part that's
the hard work that sometimes writers
don't want to do it's scary
because it's uh
you know you have to tap into your own
stuff and when you tap into your own
stuff
um then you can
you know you can share it with somebody
else and they can they can tap into
theirs and isn't that really why we're
doing all this anyway
we're sharing emotions
otherwise who cares
right
who was the first character that you you
felt a connection with
oh my goodness
a television character film television
in a book
where you really felt like you were in
that person's skin you knew you knew
that world you knew who they were wow
that's a i don't even know
i don't even know if i could
rewind the tapes
to tell you where that first
person was although i will tell you
there may have been okay this is going
to sound really weird but it's a
children's book
one of my very favorite children's books
was a book and i don't even i don't
think it's in print anymore it's called
anne likes red
red red red a blue dress and
no i like red red red i read it so much
and
i don't know
if that was
because i i think it might have been
because there was so much of me in that
i loved red but i also just loved her
determination that she was really
focused that there was just this um
sense of this
young girl and i again i must have been
in grade school if not even before it's
probably you know preschool book where i
just
i memorized every single line of that
book
you know what i do i do know what it was
i do know what it was that just sparked
something so there was another book at
around the same time when i was really
young
and again i don't know if
i could even tell you the name of it
but it was a book about a young girl
who
had all these
dolls and they were of all different
colors from all different countries
and she wanted a doll that looked just
like her
and i i think at the very end the the
doll maker made her doll that looked
exactly like her now she happened to be
a blonde little blind girl
but the fact that there were that this
book
had dolls that looked like me they were
all sorts of beautiful dolls and
different
clothing from different countries
and again that was something that i
think for me was like yeah there's
there's difference and i'm one of the
different ones i'm one of the other ones
and wouldn't i love a doll that looked
like me and i identified with a girl but
i also identified with all those other
dolls because i looked like that
um
so yeah oh is that that's a really
interesting
little
piece of like something that you just
unearthed there that's interesting
i'm going to have to find that but i
think i don't i do know that i still
have i still have that book i i own that
book someplace
um and i'll have to figure that out
very cool huh i just i don't know why
i'm just yeah thinking i know because
cost plus world market they would have
these different little dots very
international and i always liked going
there too because it wasn't you know
yeah i had a barbie and a skipper and
all right it was it was just like you
know just the same thing every time
perfectly straight hair which i couldn't
have you know right right right
yeah i think there was that whole i had
a lot of
alexander dolls and i had a lot of
different um
different colors and you know different
dresses and
yeah that was a great book
i wonder if there's a movie in that book
but there's a movie in that book oh
okay there you go adaptation
why do you say the best ideas are
personal
okay so
i'll say that i'll say this for and and
maybe let's see if we can come at it for
a couple of different ways
so
um
it's obviously difficult to
to write a screenplay or to write a a
pilot right it's it's a hard thing to do
if everybody did it there there'd be a
jillion of them they were just amazing
it's hard to do but again as we talked
about connecting and being able to
understand those characters you really
need to get underneath all of those all
of the
the the trappings of this is a really
cool story to get to
the why of it all and the um
and the emotion because again that's
what's going to
make you want to lean forward it's going
to make you want to come see it again
it's going to make you want to show up
week to week right
is if you know and understand and you
love these characters um or i should say
at least understand those characters
because you may not love some of these
anti-hero characters but you can
understand them
and um
and the
and what do we all have that's different
from somebody else it's our own personal
experiences so i can't write your story
you can't write my story
um
so that's what makes us special so if
we're going to be able to dredge up as
writers our whole goal is to dredge up
all of that stuff and to
convey it in a way that's going to
connect us
and for you to feel what i feel
you need to be able to tap into all of
that well what's the best story it's the
one that you have that you own
so um
i do think that the
when i was
running the
the access program for hbo
we always looked for
writers who could access that really
quickly
people who were willing and already
there at a place where
all of their personal stuff was just at
the surface where you didn't have to to
go through a therapy session for them to
unload
all of their stuff because that stuff is
the stuff that makes a script
really resonate
and you can tell when someone is really
willing to to go there otherwise
everything is very cute plotty you know
surfacy but it's not really um
moving
so uh so i do think that there's an
important piece of that switches
use the stuff that you have
which is
you know all of you and put that on the
page
and then you can place that whatever
that little ball of stuff is in any
situation you want so it doesn't have to
be that you're you know writing
specifically about your life it doesn't
have to be a autobiography but it should
that kernel of that
of that idea in the center of it
should be transferable to
a story no matter where it takes place
and it's the more truthful you are the
more authentic you are in your writing
the better you're writing
i know for a fact excuse me i know where
for a fact when i write
if i'm not being truthful and i have to
go back and then go another layer and go
okay how do i really tap into this
character and i have to do the work
because you know and i think people can
you can feel it people can feel it
when you are being
really truthful and when you're not
being truthful
when you're doing it for cutesy sake
versus you're doing it because you're as
i call it opening of a nat onto a page
have you ever had to tell a writer that
like maybe not in those exact words but
i feel like you're holding something
back or maybe we need to go another
layer
you know somebody just said that to me
recently
they said i think you can go deeper and
i went oh
i was caught and i went yeah i know
but it was hard it was a hard thing to
do
and when i and so this was a script i
actually just turned it in um to my
manager recently and he was the one who
gave me the note and he said
so you can do a little better
and um and the story was very much about
me in college so it's a it's it's a
horror sci-fi there's like some really
cool stuff that happens in it
but the character at the center was me
in college
and
um
and i
and he knew when i knew
that i had not done the work
i had done most of the work i hadn't
done all the work that i could have done
and i went back and i rewrote the entire
script and even throughout the entire
storyline i just and i went and i went
okay
i was writing i did a lot of
a story but i hadn't really done the b
stories i hadn't really fleshed out the
other characters i was quick to get to
the finish line
and when i went back and i tore the
whole thing apart and put it back
together again and then went back to the
original story but i had to do some of
that work in order to
figure out who everybody else was in
this world
it was i'm gonna say a thousand times
better
he was absolutely right i needed to do
the work
and i hadn't wanted to do the work and i
thought well i could get my
kind of cool
slick idea
but i and i thought like i said i said i
thought i had done some of it but i
hadn't done all of it
so um so it does work and yeah you have
to give those notes all the time and i
think that how you give that note though
is
important is just as important as the
note itself
and
sometimes a good coaxing or a good
question
you know hey what were you trying to get
to here or what's the theme as you see
it and what's the big question that
you're trying to answer and
you know how do we help you get there
sometimes those can be a lot better than
hey this wasn't great or
you know
you can if you compose it in the
you know jeopardy way of asking a
question question
then sometimes the uh
sometimes those answers come organically
to the writer sure what would alex
trebek say yeah yeah exactly
but were you do you think you were doing
it in too much of a cutesy way
no i think i had i think i had a
i hadn't
i acknowledged to myself that
like i said i had done some of the work
i had done quite a bit of the work what
i hadn't done was the hardest part of
the work which is when you go a deep a
layer deeper
and
the
i think the part of it that was
the light bulb that went on for me was
that i hadn't written her emotions
i had written
what she was doing and why she was doing
it
i had the stakes in there i had
everything else
i hadn't gone back and done the work of
um
of tapping into what i was feeling at
the time and why the story was important
and what was the thing that was driving
me to write it why beyond the idea
was it important to me it's a story that
i had i had actually written a draft of
this in 2009
so it's something that i kept holding on
to
and i realized that there are themes in
it that were really important to me that
i keep coming back to in other work
and
and so i knew i had to do finally do the
work and go okay this is really me it's
the setting was was vassar everything
about it was was
every single building in it was a
sensory you know memory
coming back to me
and the the fear was
well what if i exposed too much of
myself
and so i had to let go of that fear and
go okay let me expose
how i was feeling and why i was doing
what i was doing and what was that
journey that i was on and why was that
and so important and that was the key i
think and when you can do that in your
work when you can really
pull back the layers on your
um
on your
your own journey
and try to ask your questions of well
why was that important why was that
important well what touched a nerve
there and what was the why did you feel
so alone at that moment and
um
and what was the the tension that you
were feeling with those people at the
time
um i really get underneath that that's
when
things start to really pop